grazie grazie anche asino per la
splendida presentazione feed your mind
with robotics rautis ma il nostro motto
ovvero utilizzare il robot all'interno
dell'autismo per nutrire ovvero
stimolare fare una sorta di palestra per
la mente di nutrimento per la mente
attraverso i robot questo che vedete in
foto è una parte del team siamo tutti
informatici appassionati di robotica
perché appassionati robotica perché le
nostre origini partono negli anni
settanta e ottanta quando eravamo
bambini e seguivamo i primi carter
animati famosissimi di go nagai
mazinga goldrake
siamo rimasti talmente impressionati che
negli anni abbiamo cercato di
trasformare quello che era un cartone
animato in una realtà come cominciando a
studiare la robotica che però fino a
qualche anno fa era una materia
abbastanza irraggiungibile
nel senso che era
riservato a pochi i robot costavano
cifre veramente impressionanti ma questo
fino al 2012 anno in cui abbiamo
acquistato il nostro primo robot e
abbiamo cominciato a studiarlo né alla
ricerca di un'applicazione che potesse
far sì che uomini e robot di potessero
in qualche modo diventare amici cos'è
l'autismo è perché ci siamo dedicati e
l'autismo perché il primo progetto è
stato quello di utilizzare questi robot
all'interno della terapia dell'autismo
per chi non lo sapesse l'autismo è
caratterizzato da una triade di tre
caratteristiche
problemi nel verbali comportamenti
stereo ripa stereotipati e ripetitivi e
scarsa interazione sociale
questi tre elementi combinati insieme
fanno sì che queste questi bambini
speciali hanno difficoltà di inserimento
un altro mito legato all autismo o
giusto apro una piccolissima parentesi è
quella dei dei vaccini questo lo devo i
medici che mi chiedono sempre di fare
questo passaggio in realtà è una
correlazione assolutamente casuale non è
non è affatto avere stata più volte
smentita questa cosa le origini casomai
sono genetiche in cui giusto per
curiosità ammetto ho messo due grafici
che evidenziano delle correlazioni
assurde come l'aumento degli omicidi
delle nazioni dove c'è maggior utilizzo
di internet explorer è l'aumento
dell'autismo nei con la dove si
consumano più cibi biologici chiaramente
una correlazione voluta e forzata così
come autismo e vaccini
ritornando al discorso di prima perché i
robot quello di che cosa centra un robot
umanoide
all'interno di una terapia dell'autismo
due mondi assolutamente distanti che
realtà si parlano
questo è stata la prima sfida c'era
tanta letteratura in giro nel mondo sui
primi esperimenti con pupazzi evoluti e
robot abbiamo approfondito abbiamo
studiato abbiamo fatto un accordo con il
cnr con diverse università e istituti
perché non sono informati ci avevamo
bisogno della parte medica
neuropsichiatri infantili psicologi e
abbiamo visto che il robot risponde a
quella che loro chiamano le contingenze
perfette cioè oggetti assolutamente
prevedibili che non prendono iniziativa
è altamente ripetitivi questo
garantiscono una certa tranquillità e
serenità nei confronti dei di questi
bambini speciali li aiutano diventando
per loro dei catalizzatori e attenzione
e dei grandi motivatori perché non
dimentichiamoci che sono bambini devono
giocare e se il gioco si trasforma in un
secondo il paradigma dell'edutainment
c'è un gioco forma mirato la formazione
allora abbiamo ottenuto un primo un
primo risultato ma la vera sfida
all'inizio quale era rendere semplice e
una piattaforma complessa come della
robotica
semplice e nei confronti di medici
terapisti e genitori in quanto
tipicamente il robot è un oggetto
che si presta a un programmatore insomma
una persona che ha una certa esperienza
allora abbiamo creato una piattaforma
che abbiamo battezzato con il nome di
robot m robot amico in qualche modo
vuole rappresentare questa frase in modo
che con tre click attraverso un tablet
l'operatore del settore posso utilizzare
questi robot e quindi non diventa un
onere utilizzarlo all'interno della
terapia ma diventa uno strumento in più
che gli consente di essere un
osservatore privilegiato in quanto il
robot che si occupa di fare gli esercizi
e di stimolare il bambino ma perché i
bambini interagiscono con il robot come
questo è un video il primissimo video
che abbiamo realizzato
dove abbiamo preso il nostro primo robot
e l'abbiamo fatto interagire con questo
fantastico bambino le ti vedo dopo il
nostro testimonial lui è un bambino
autistico anche se guardando questo
video nessuno ci crede perché se vi
dicessi che lui e ipercinetico e non
stavo un attimo fermo non ci crede
nessuno visto che così concentrato su
l'utilizzo del robot per un tempo in cui
è stato sintetizzato in pochi minuti fa
è stato tre quarti d'ora c'era il padre
in lacrime perché ci ha raccontato che
mai aveva visto il figlio
soffermarsi su una singola attività per
più di un minuto e la cosa simpatica
anche che lui cerca di condividere il
pallone i suoi giocattoli con il robot
dopo pochi minuti
dal primo contatto quindi non lo vede
come un giocattolo ma lo vede come un
compagno di giochi
il surrogato dell'essere umano il robot
diventa un compagnetto di giochi questo
è straordinario perché aiuta tantissimo
la terapista tenerlo
concentrato lì dalla positiva di poterci
lavorare giocando con vedete lo tocca lo
accarezza lui anche affetto anche da
deficit verbale e si sforzava di parlare
per richiedere il robot facesse
determinazione questo non è un setting
da laboratori corretto è stato
semplicemente la prima esperienza per
verificare come poteva interagire un
bambino come un robot visto che non ci
sono dei precedenti
successivamente abbiamo strutturato il
laboratorio in un determinato modo
abbiamo creato un protocollo di
interazione un protocollo di
somministrazione
quest'altra vista importante dove quando
avete visto che il bambino punta lo
sguardo perché loro hanno difficoltà a
riconoscere le emozioni non incrociano
gli occhi e lo sguardo
dell'interlocutore perché non hanno
sviluppato come dicevo prima interazione
sociale
il robot che attraverso la sua
telecamera inquadra gli occhi del
bambino e realizza il trekking oculare
uno strumento fantastico perché in
questo modo posso vedere l'andamento
della terapia perché vado a monitorare
come il bambino piano piano concentra
sempre di più lo sguardo verso il volto
del robot quindi lo strumento
informatico diventa significativo
abbiamo
quindi provato a realizzare un qualcosa
che finalmente potesse andare sul
mercato perché la ricerca è bellissima e
fantastica però a volte
come dico io non è profeticamente
corretta nel senso che realizza alle
cose fantastiche che poi però rimangono
nei laboratori non vanno sul mercato e
questo non è giusto perché nel momento
in cui si realizza qualcosa di
interessante che possa avere delle
ricadute sociali e doveroso poterlo
proporre a tutti lo stesso riforme
diceva che c'è progresso quando una
nuova tecnologia è per tutti se me la
tengo solo io e poco significativa
per far questo abbiamo creato cercato
dei partner come cooperative sociali
ospedali università e centri di ricerca
che potessero testare la piattaforma
perché ogni bambino è un mondo a sé e
quindi la fase di test che abbiamo
iniziato da circa sei mesi
merita un lungo periodo di verifica per
poter arrivare ad una soluzione
definitiva
questo è il resto del team
si sono aggiunti negli anni perché non
l'ho detto prima ma noi siamo una start
up
nata nel 2013
negli anni si sono aggiunti nuovi
elementi del team tra cui i due
investitori che hanno creduto in noi
hanno investito i loro soldi
direttamente nella nella startup che ci
supportano anche dal punto di vista
marketing perché è il nostro obiettivo
di realizzare questa piattaforma è stato
solo l'inizio
vorremmo noi utilizzare i robot in modo
più intenso e creando anche un nuovo
paradigma dell'utilizzo però quello di
realizzare l'inclusione sociale di
questi bambini autistici e non solo uno
strumento per la terapia che alla lunga
potrebbe rischiare di cristallizzare il
bambino con i robot paradossalmente
perché vi assicuro gli piace così tanto
che poi non si stacca più e allora se
invece all'interno della tra pienza e
disco un bambino neuro tipico che può
essere il fratellino il compagnetto
anche i genitori il robot diventa un
mediatore che attraverso il gioco e la
collaborazione li aiuta a interagire per
che l'autismo non è una patologia ma è
un deficit del comportamento è un
disturbo del comportamento che si può
sintetizzare una frase come un problema
di comunicazione
se io trovo un nuovo modo per far
comunicare a due persone ho raggiunto
l'obiettivo
oltre questo può essere benissimo
utilizzato come piattaforma di training
per i genitori
e per i terapisti posso far diventare
passatemi il termine il robot autistico
e cioè fargli simulare il comportamento
di mille bambini perchè come avete visto
fino alle espressioni facciali può
riprodurre emozioni e allora in questo
modo trasformi il robot in un soggetto
autistico e diventa una piattaforma di
prova per i genitori che anziché far le
prove sul figlio o i terapisti sui figli
degli altri restano su robot e imparano
e se riusciamo a realizzare questo
sicuramente
ci portiamo avanti con la nostra idea di
far sì che uomini e robot possono
finalmente essere amici e non più i
nemici da abbattere
come nei film di fantascienza dove
devono necessariamente conquistare il
mondo e uccidere tutti gli umani
grazie